here's a question for aspiring the
screenwriters is it possible to make the
movie passengers better with some
relatively minor changes you know I
don't think this is a really bad film
after hearing reviews from friends and
online I sort of expected it to be but I
think that feeling was mostly
disappointed expectation passengers is
by no means a train wreck it's just
really really predictable the plot goes
like this
after the interstellar spaceship Avalon
malfunctions Chris Pratt wakes up from
hyper asleep 90 years before he's
supposed to 90 years before anyone else
on the ship he can't go back to sleep
he can't contact her if he can't get to
the ship's controls he tries to do all
of these things and fails as a year
passes he grows increasingly sad and
hopeless so eventually he decides to
wake up another passenger Jennifer
Lawrence condemning her to the same fate
essentially death in order to give
himself some more company he acts like
gets another malfunction he doesn't tell
her after a while they fall in love she
finds out the truth gets really mad and
then the ship begins to really
malfunction
so Pratt sacrifices himself to save it
but in the end she saves him they fall
in love again and spend the rest of
their lives alone on the ship happily
ever after oh and Laurence Fishburne
sent it to hell oh my god about 12 or 13
minutes in act 3 but you know count your
blessings it's way better than what
Oscar nominated actor Andy Garcia got so
you can break this blood up into five
basic turning points one Chris wakes up
to Chris wakes Jennifer up three she
finds out for Chris sacrifices himself
and five she forgives him the most acute
tension in the film happens between
parts 2 & 3
when Jennifer starts to fall in love
with Chris but doesn't yet know the
truth we know the truth is coming is a
little dramatic irony there and so we
wait with increasing anxiety until it
does and when it does predictably
Jennifer freaks out predictably and we
feel a little sadness predictably at
this point exactly an hour into the
movie the script has sort of written
itself into a corner because Pratt is
the real main character because we spend
30 minutes alone with him at the start
of the film and see everything through
his eyes there's really only two paths
to take regarding the central
relationship either
is or she forgives him in both ways he
finds absolution for the sin he
committed because you're not going to be
able to turn him bad not a character
like this not unless you have five
seasons to do it and yes I know there
are some allusions to the shining here
but the shining spent pretty much no
time at all endearing us to the
character of Jack Torrance passenger
spends the whole first act endearing us
to the lovable scrappy Chris Pratt it's
clear the creators or the studio were
intent on this being a love story so
they chose to go with the schmaltzy
ending but they could have chosen either
the last 45 minutes would have been the
same a movie pretty much devoid of real
tension or suspense which requires a
completely new plot device in the third
act the total malfunction of the ship to
juice the ending with some adrenaline
you know a couple weeks ago I was
watching Chris stuckman and Doug
Walker's joint review of passengers and
Walker said something interesting if
they told this in a different order yeah
when they've been ten times more
insurance yes the thing I began to
wonder is what if you rearranged the
movie so that Jennifer Lawrence was the
point-of-view character not Chris Pratt
what if the film began with her
experience well I couldn't stop thinking
about it so i readed the existing
footage see what would happen to the
story
[Music]
good morning Aurora how are you feeling
you just spent 120 years in suspended
animation
[Music]
Grand Concourse anybody
hello hi hey passenger accrue passenger
Jim Preston do you know what's going on
nobody else from my row will cut same
for me when I made this change and just
watched from there some interesting
things started to happen first of all
the first act changes its tone entirely
with the original first act you're
wandering around the ship with Chris
Pratt you learn cool things you see him
come to terms with the situation have
fun get depressed and finally reached
the ethical dilemma that's meant to
animate the movie what you see is what
you get here which makes for a somewhat
passive viewing experience it's an
amusing sequence but that's mostly down
to cool production design and Pratt's
always charming performance yes I am
gonna die of old age on this ship but in
the new first act the story is infused
from the start with mystery when I made
the editing changes I was genuinely
surprised by just how creepy Pratt's
character is when you take away his
point of view we don't know whether to
trust him or not believe him or not and
that makes the audience's experience an
active one in every moment do you know
it's going on nobody else from my row
look same for me as he leads Jennifer
around the ship locations become crime
scenes where the viewer tries to figure
out what's happening this of course by
the way is what makes andrei tarkovsky
solaris so great so much has happened on
Solaris by the time the lead character
arrives that he and the audience have to
piece the fragments together themselves
I mean just look at how creepy he is I
actually think that Pratt's performance
takes on more dimensions from this angle
you're not always forced to see him as
sympathetic so his darker side comes out
in greater relief more important than
that the dark choice that sits at the
heart of this film hits with greater
impact when seen from the first time
from Lawrence's perspective because we
feel the cruelty as she feels it do you
wake me up
[Music]
I try not to so now we're at the point
where the original story hits that dead
end but with this new edit you have some
more options to play with namely with
this configuration you could actually
turn Pratt into the villain the original
film suggests but can't follow through
on and make passengers into the thriller
horror film that so many critics wanted
to see you could even cut back in that
whole first section of Chris's time
alone on the ship but put it after the
revelation without the need to justify
his good guy nnessee could show a deeper
more desperate side to his loneliness
something that I think actually would
make him more sympathetic in the end and
the choice he makes more agonizing
[Music]
[Music]
of course this simple cut and paste
doesn't solve every problem in the
script the ending for example is still
an issue I think you'd want to remove
the malfunction MacGuffin but it might
be just as trite to close the story in
true horror fashion it could be cool to
give it a Twilight Zone ending as Peters
credits slash films suggested and have
Pratt die and Laurence gets so lonely
that she begins to contemplate the same
horrible choice brainstorming like this
is obviously really fun and much easier
than actually writing a movie and making
one for all its faults passengers is a
big-budget movie with a completely
original script and that should be
celebrated because it's a dying breed
but if then like this is a good
opportunity for would-be screenwriters
to think about story because you can
learn just as much from films that don't
work as you can from those that do hey
everybody thank you so much for watching
this episode was brought to you by
Dollar Shave Club you might have noticed
that I have a beard everybody with the
beard will tell you that if you don't
keep things clean it can get really
scruffy really quickly so I use Dollar
Shave Club razors to make sure all the
the lines on my neck and cheeks are
smooth and even and it's the smarter
choice because they send everything you
need right to your door at an affordable
price you have to go to the store you
don't have to spend money on unnecessary
technology and for a limited time you
can get the executive razor with a tube
of dr. Carver's shade butter for just $5
no shipping fee and razors are only a
few bucks a month after that here's what
you get in the box get a nice sturdy
handle and get your four razors and of
course dr. Carver's shea butter don't
leave home without it make sure you mean
really easy no commitments no hassles
and if you go to dollarshaveclub.com
slash nerdwriter you can get that first
month for five dollars the links at the
top of the description that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash nerdwriter
thanks guys I'll see you next week